wo ist dein leben
so war schnitzel als dankeschön markt
sehr nett last so schnell guten appetit
nico guten appetit engel
ich habe gehört du spielst fußball ja
stimmt spiels wird uns zusammen fußball
nächste woche was machst du denn noch in
deiner freizeit joggt gerne nein nicht
joggen nicht gern aber ich stimme
manchmal ich höre viel musik und fahre
viel fahrrad
aber am liebsten mache ich das da ja ich
gehe
na das ist ja was die beiden halt doch
auch wenn wir zeit haben die nach der
ins theater und ins kino aber am
liebsten einen werden kann man ja ich
zeig dir ein paar fotos ich suche die
fotos vom letzten jahr
es war verrückt erst habe ich gar nichts
gefallen wollte schon aufgeben
und dann zieht es und heraus kam ein
riesiger hecht muss sein das ist ja
du bist ja das ist meine tante
jara ist eine tante ja meine tante